- So in one of the crazier legal things
that I've heard in a very long time,
Lady Gaga's dogs were apparently kidnapped
or I guess dog napped
and people are wondering
what were the actual crimes
that were committed here?
Well, there were a bunch
and as much as we love dogs
and they are a part of the family,
they are also considered property.
So it is theft, it's conversion to try
and steal someone's dog.
Many states, including California
have specific laws about
trying to take someone's dog.
But, on top of about these
robbers actually used a gun
and shot the dog walker, who
was walking Lady Gaga's dog.
Now that is aggravated robbery,
when you use a deadly
weapon to commit a robbery,
that is what makes it aggravated.
So that's clearly a crime there,
but the fact that they shot the dog walker
means that this also qualifies
as attempted murder as well
and we're just lucky that
the dog walker survived.
Thankfully the dogs had been returned,
but if these criminals are ever found
they're going to jail for
a very, very long time.
So as always subscribe
or I'll see you in court.